bella tutti ragazzi ben vedere questo
video sono parigi siamo ritornati su
hunger games però oggi abbiamo una
puntata un pochettino speciale perché
come ho detto sabato scorso sono usciti
finalmente it atac quelli che vi ho
fatto vedere la settimana scorsa che
sarebbero questi qui anzi facciamo una
cosa professionale sono usciti sono
riusciti questi o per finalmente
finalmente un utilizzo decente per il
great per trovarli ragazzi basta andare
ridicolo a chiedere il magazine web
start hancock e in omaggio milano ilda
tac e in onore di questo è uscita dai
d'attacco voluto fare la puntata di
bianche renzo appunto un pelo speciale
perché vi presento i team di oggi
ragazzi che si affronteranno nei
miliardesimi hunger games bayliss 30
ragazzi abbiamo step ever e new entry
degli hunger games bayliss 32 abbiamo
cristiano e ninja che cristiano youtube
però non sono tutti youtuber bene
distretto n
andiamo daniele jacopo nonché ipantellas
per il distretto 4 abbiamo cocco e più
di fi per il distretto 5 abbiamo
cannavacciuolo è diventata uno youtuber
collegato la pacca sulla avanti regate e
donald trump per il distretto 6 sfera e
basta e alberto angela veri il distretto
7 farisei e samp ovviamente il mio cane
non potrà mancare ristretta toast
hackney e vegas per il distretto 9 anima
e sabrina ferilli senza 10 tudor e su
ribery distretto 11 pietro e power che
prime non sono forti uguali a fort nel
distretto 12 ovviamente come sempre vita
e che dire che questi hunger games
possono avere inizio let's golf
mentre i tributi stanno sullo podio
suona il corno calava sole cristiano
combattono per una borsa cannavacciolo
si arrende si ritira beh jacopo fugge
dalla cornucopia alberto angela trova
una borraccia piena d'acqua
steve sabrina combattono per una borsa
step si arrende e si ritira step subito
agguerrito dall'inizio anima fugge dalla
cornucopia goku afferra un baratto
riesca la pesca mentre daniel prende gli
attrezzi da pesca ma buon livello bene a
pescara sti due storie basta fare un
barattolo di esche da pesca vetro felice
di pescara io pesco con sfera e basta
beh ottimo 9 ragazzi tutti fuggiti
let's golf vediamo quanto casinò
riusciamo a creare
katniss per sé e su ricercano altri
tributi sfera e basta riceve un accetta
las vegas
alberto angela sente il potere perché
power era troppo mainstream e cristiano
che parla in onda nanza sabrina daniel
più di fi a jacopo rintracciano uccidono
pietro in quattro non cedere pietro si
ammazza anche da solo regala ninja
chiede a parigi di ucciderlo rifiuta
tenendo un ingenuità io sono scemo
perché ninja poteva già andare fuori dai
giochi invece io ho risparmiato ninja
già io che faccio fuori ninja è un'altra
vita però vabbè un colpo di cane morto
solo pietro beh meno male
some picchia più volte la testa di
alberto angela contro una roccia non lo
facevo così aggressivo il mio cane vegas
taglia severamente anima con una spada
ai a tradimento in famiglia suri
sconfigge stef in combattimento ma
risparmia la sua vita cristiano piange
se stesso per dormire stesso tende alle
ferite riferisce all amicizia quella
vera che si forma altri di essere basta
sono morti solo alberto angela anima e
daniel quindi let's go to dr.sa messuri
iniziano a combattere ma some scappa
mentre tudor uccide sul casinò
cannavacciolo tenta di accendere il
fuoco ma non ha successo metà dei saluti
fornelli
sarebbe stata un'altra storia ferie
uccide il potere anche detto power
mentre cerca di scappare quindi fare ha
ucciso power ferie quando giochi in
creative di sempre ma in battle royale
secondo me te la cavi
se le basta e ninja raccontano storie su
se stessi katniss attacca donald trump
ma fa vige lo protegge uccidendo katniss
vegas scappato lega sta facendo fuori
tutti quelli dei mei tutti sono morti
suri energia adesso pa potere è
diventato energia
vabbè katniss e peeta sono morti tutti
maledizioni tudor e sabrina si tengono
per mano a vedi quando sasha more che
succede è mamma mia quante cose strane
fame ninja si stringono attorno al
calore se mi rubi il cane altro che
batte royale e ti faccio cadere
l'autobus di format in testa fair e
rimane sveglio tutta la notte però è una
ragazza quindi dovresti cambiare però
vabbè non fa niente
ninja uccide cannavacciuolo mentre dorme
beh questa cosa
non è che non avrei mai pensato lega
succede jacopo con ma vegas è un killer
di vento questo successo a vegas tudor
scatta il collo di fa vj lì mi ha fatto
fuori tudor scattando il collo cosa vuol
dire scattare un collo lo scopriremo in
un prossimo episodio fatto sta che sono
morto io quindi tudor ti odio ninja
colpisce sun mentre di volta la schiena
anni già fatto fuori summer of love e
sabrina costringe coco c del ferro tudor
deciso di uccidere tudor fair e sabrina
e ninja liti che non sa bene uccida
offriremo fallimento entrambi koch umore
ben ipotermia ha vinto sabrina come rito
sabrina l'ha detta ha portato fortuna al
tatà che sabrina va bene al mio di un
casinò è successa vinto sabrina tra
tutti come sabrina maledizione ci avevo
creduto ista partita porca vacca
vorrei dai è finita male come finale
pensavo di fare un po di più io però
sono morto 2000 ci rifacciamo nella
prossima micro pausa avete presente i
data che quelli che potete trovare in
edicola tre ore 99 e proprio l'oro
edicola roba che molti mi hanno chiesto
in realtà partitiche lo scorso episodio
di gente non aveva capito qua dietro che
ci sia scritto io ho scritto più scritti
i capelli ci si può trovare una stella
dorata che è molto molto rara e se
trovate la stella qua dietro invece che
questa scritta vincente un video
messaggio personalizzato tra l'altro ho
notato ho provato a scartarne 18 tra sci
a vincere il videomessaggio di giuseppe
tanto dietro su giuseppe già scritto
we're all mail non è vero
mentre in tributi stanno sul podio suona
il corno stavolta devo fare bene
cristiano jacopo vegas e sfiora e basta
formano un patto suicida uccidendosi
bene iniziata benissimo la partita anima
spaventa sabrina che coppia stesse
riceve forniture mediche da uno sponsor
sconosciuto il solito raccomandato ester
raccomandato che andava ciolos cappa
d'afa vj e non è andata proprio così
proprio no che andava cielo si
addormenta ingessando raccontano storie
basta ninja col mio cane ma cosa c'è che
il mio cane power pita minacciano un
doppio suicidio fallisce muoiono e tutto
suicidio questo landi renzo attenzione
incredibile una nube di fumo e velenose
inizia a riempire l'arena questa è una
cosa che succede molto raramente e
succedono sempre casini quando arrivano
quindi tudor si sacrifica in modo che
step di possa andarsene quindi tutto era
saldato stern i cockoo si sacrifica in
modo che alberto angela
beh questo è chiaro alberto deve
sopravvivere pietro e katniss decidono
di correre insieme della nuvola ninja
sopravvive perché abituato alla nube di
formia sul rianima decidono di correre
insieme nella nuvola tutti stanno norma
che succede o stanno facendo fuori tutti
qui poi sopravvive dall'altra sopravvive
step sopravvive fa vj sopravvive che la
voce lo sopravvive sabrina immersa nella
nuvola quindi anche le andata via per e
sopravvive same avvolto no il mio cane
andato via martini 11 energia vita
daniel tudor goku pietro cat missouri
anima sabrina e stam fere falli j si
incontrano e decidono di fare la tregua
per la notte sarà poco contento stefano
forse ma non è morto perché sarà allora
il set sarà preso malissimo step mette a
fuoco ferie con a mollo troppo la
litigheranno ogni tanto anche loro
purtroppo ragazzi sono rimasti in
pochissimi veri alberto angela se ne
vanno
tensione step sorprende cannavacciuolo
alla sprovvista e lo uccide fa vg cerca
di curare la sua infezione min già
ricevono esplosivo da uno sponsor step
di strangola pili poi dopo impegnarsi in
una scazzottata
quindi siamo veramente sul filo del
rasoio fare g spaventa step li ascolta
ninja donald trump che parlano in
lontananza procedere sono dati il
canovaccio le più di paese o rimasti in
cinque ragazzi fa vicentin dalle ferite
ma perché io curo donald trump
ma perché
sta simpatico e non al trump step e
parigi si dividono per cercare risorse
attenzione escono queste fiumi tradisce
qua ninja dei capitals terni mingere
capita tutti oggi mamma mia
kakà ninja in finale non me lo vorrei
mai trovato davanti è però vabbè
procedere propri scatta silenziosamente
il collo di donald trump e lo sapevo
erano terra tutta una tattica il ninja
sopraffà stef uccidendolo finale
incredibile fa vj ninja ragazzi sono in
finale
ti prego non ce la farei mai a vincere
la finale con i gen un batter royale ma
almeno negli hunger games
ti prego fa vj ti prego ninja scaglia fa
vigenti con una mazza sono arto
maledetta la vita mi odio forca vacca
four cani anti in finale li yang o capi
nel battero jano vincerai mai ma almeno
degli hunger games ti prego non c'è
neanche il tata lui ma per favore niente
raramente mi riguarda ho provato ci ho
provato
quindi spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
gli hunger games si concludono qua
fatemi sapere se trovate la stella d'oro
dei tabacchi che vi mando un saluto come
al solito servizio è piaciuto ho scelto
come l'hai anche i vari socialmente
video tratto da schizzare è segnata da
questi iscrivetevi come sempre noi ci
vediamo l'anno prossimo minuto bel
ragazzo
[Musica]